well the ACLU has been around a long
time and it built its reputation
defending free speech and especially due
process especially for the politically
unpopular it saved lives at the
beginning of its existence that was the
whole point of the ACLU those
traditional principles are being washed
away though in the tide of derangement
that has now seized the left and the
ACLU has decided to join that tide they
are now running an ad declaring
Cavanaugh guilty without the need for a
trial or in fact any evidence watch
we've seen this before
denials from powerful men I did not have
sexual relations with that woman
anything like this I categorically and
unequivocally deny the allegation
against me by dr. Ford America is
watching and as we choose a lifetime
seat on our highest court integrity
matters and we cannot have any doubt
senator Gardner oppose the confirmation
of Judge Cavanaugh christen is a radio
show host former aide to Senator Chuck
Schumer probably a donor to the ACLU and
he joins us tonight Chris it's great to
see you so you're you know pushing late
middle-aged like I am you've been around
long enough to remember what the ACLU
has been doing for their weight whatever
unless you know you're probably over 30
but you might watch the ACLU over time
and you know they were founded to defend
free speech and due process civil
liberties and yet here they just ran an
ad suggesting a man is guilty on the
basis of no evidence because he shares
some resemblance to two other guys who
are probably guilty that's guilt by
association as the opposite of due
process why is the ACLU doing this I
wonder well they're not declaring him
guilty in fact I don't think anybody's
trying to declare him guilty what we're
trying to do is pick a Supreme Court
justice and guilt or innocence really
not the issue here he's not on trial for
his life he's applying for a job
he's got to ask the question has he been
truthful in that inquiry and the answer
is no I would say I don't know for sure
about the sexual assault allegation
although I do believe dr. Ford but I do
know that some of the
they talked about laughing okay so
before we get to what you think he
specifically lied about I just want to
rewind a second to what you said cuz it
strikes me as amazing you're saying that
without finding someone guilty of
anything it's okay to destroy his
reputation to the point where he can't
get paying work and can't get the job
that he was nominated for by the
president United States no I'm serious
he just had to withdraw as a lecturer at
Harvard because this reputation has been
so sullied he hasn't found guilty of
anything there's no actual evidence to
show he did anything but that's okay
with you because we're not in a trial is
that what you're saying that's the new
standard what I'm saying is you got to
ask the question is this man fit for a
lifetime appointment that will never
ever face the voters will never face
Congress again and if you feel in your
heart that this man may have committed
this thing or he hasn't been truthful to
that committee well I will tell you I
don't believe it I just want to get you
lied but that's unprovable so it's not
even worth debating on TV I would say
but to the firaon at this table is if
you feel in your heart so if I feel in
my heart they're a child molester I
don't have any actual evidence can I
start telling people that on TV and see
how it affects your family and how it
affects your employment well your kids
think I am well know if I feel in my
heart like sincerely feel in my heart
I'm not I'm not trying to get a lifetime
appointment on the bench and nobody's
accusing them of anything credibly
accused well I know it's quite a little
cute no but hold on hold on
you just been a cancer of a lot of
things credibly is a subjective term is
it okay if you quote feel in your heart
that someone's guilty to systematically
destroy him and his family and you're
saying yes because it's so important
because abortion or whatever but is that
dinner you want to learn you find did
you find dr. Ford credible I'm not
really sure I she wasn't asked real
questions like for example when did you
recall this have you known it for 30
years and not set it to one person and
then told your therapist about it that's
a year that's for the basic question
nobody asked it because they're too
afraid enough to know that that's a
you're smart enough to know that
traumatic experiences sometimes you only
remember that I don't know
no questions on my show I'm not bullied
into silence by a bunch of I think I
think I think you've found her credible
too but you know he lied about what the
Renata alumni was he lied about what the
Ralph's club was he lied to Congress he
can't you're saying he lied about the
Ralph's club over done I agree you lie
about a club and you're done I feel that
in my heart let me just say okay you
especially might think my think time I
think Tucker is why I lie about that it
was something he could have just said I
was a dumb kid and I did you know what
let's me Ralph when we drank I'm gonna
let see of the lips too hard a prank he
could have just said that instead he
lied okay with the last word in the
Ralph's Club croissant thank you very
much